we know from today's prime minister's
questions that list trust is not just
focused on the price of energy but on
energy security too so what did we learn
about her plans she said that she wants
more drilling in the north sea would
that work well the uk's fossil fuel
industry trade group claims there's
about 15 billion barrels of oil and gas
equivalent left that's enough to power
the uk for 30 years
but campaigners say that a lot of that
oil and gas won't be commercially viable
and that the north sea is a declining
basin we've extracted most of the
available gas and much of what's left is
oil 80 percent of which is exported
the other issue here is time in the next
three years there are around 40 fields
up for final approval to begin drilling
but getting to production can take years
and in some cases decades
so what else could liztrust do to
increase our energy security
one option is fracking for shale gas we
have deposits all over the country
but this is the big one here the bowling
shale reserve
during her campaign liz trust pledged to
lift the moratorium on fracking as long
as there was local support to do so but
that might be a problem the moratorium
was imposed in the first place because
the last time we tried fracking it
caused earthquakes and as a result huge
community opposition there's also very
little consensus on the quality of
available gas down there and how much we
can actually extract so what else
at pmqs liz trust also spoke about the
importance of nuclear energy so we can
expect for example continued support for
the new sizewell sea nuclear plant here
on the suffolk coast
but this option has its drawbacks too
nuclear may be clean and reliable but
it's expensive the new sizewell sea
plant is expected to cost somewhere in
the region of 20 billion pounds and
while it could produce seven percent of
the uk's electricity supply when
complete even if it all goes well it
won't be ready until at least 2031.
critics of liz trust have said that she
is too focused on fossil fuels and that
she needs to invest more in renewable
energy and a national home insulation
program
they say it is the only way to solve the
twin climate and energy emergencies at
the same time